handsome yeah wait what do you mean it's
a girl up what do you mean I'm a girl no
I'm a boy
I'm a boy I'm a girl you're a girl now
Dwayne The Rock Johnson giving new
meaning to the phrase tickled pink daddy
makes her laugh the action star
transforms in his latest Instagram video
thanks to his youngest daughter's
seven-year-old Jasmine and four-year-old
Tiana Who tricked him into a makeover
no I don't need more makeup I think I'm
good
the former pro wrestler explains in the
caption he was supposed to have a zoom
meeting but it got canceled that's when
his two tornadoes went to work I really
have a feeling I'm good
what I don't need blender yeah as The
Rock puts it his girls showed him no
mercy as a result he learned a lesson
about Glam the hard way I spend an hour
trying to scrub lipstick off my head and
face unbeknownst to me this stains the
skin but the actor says he wouldn't have
it any other way wondering hashtag maybe
I do need blender I really have a
feeling I'm good
but this is hardly the first time Jazzy
and T have pulled off an epic prank
today
close your eyes okay okay all right
I trust you
yeah how
about a wake-up call uh oh no
oh
and when it comes to uh skincare let's
just say the girls are keeping it a top
priority for Dad
clearly Dwayne's got a full plate pun
intended between his career as an actor
and life as a dad leaving no time for
politics much to his fans dismay I have
wrestled with this decision I have been
asked from very influential people on
both sides of the aisle for me to run
I'm a patriot I love our country and
everybody in it right now it's those
little girls yeah for now Dwayne's on
Daddy Duty the most important role for
me right now is father and Daddy to
these little girls who have worked so
hard over the years to get to this point
right now where we're enjoying life I
got every drop off every pickup bedtime
routine the life that I want for them
and the stability that I want for them
frankly that I really never had when I
was a little boy so we may not see
Dwayne in the white house but here's
hoping we get plenty more moments with
whipped cream water balloons and wacky
face painting what do you mean I'm a
girl no I'm a boy yeah
[Music]